the new york state lawmakers will meet
this morning to discuss their
impeachment investigation of governor
andrew cuomo
his top aide announced last night she is
resigning
11 women have accused cuomo of sexual
harassment one of them brittany comisso
has filed a criminal complaint against
him she told her story in an exclusive
interview with cbs this morning in
albany's times union
newspaper what would be the appropriate
punishment do you think for the governor
is it enough
if he were to just resign
i do think he needs to resign and i also
do think that he needs to
see counseling i do think that he needs
professional help i do think that he you
know he has
many things that he needs to work
through
commisso who still works in the
governor's office told us she has met
with impeachment investigators they're
giving cuomo's lawyers until friday
to submit evidence in his defense the
governor denies all allegations of
sexual misconduct
so that was an important point that she
still works
in the governor's office and she talks
about being conflicted in a way where
she
has experienced sort of the hostile work
environment that she's described she
said it's a very high pressure
job but she also said there's some good
people in that office
in fact those two folks who came to her
aid when she said she was watching that
news conference and was clearly
uh you know disturbed by what she heard
we've also talked often about the hopes
and aspirations and dreams
of young people who find themselves in
situations like this who all they ever
wanted
was to work in government or work in
media or work in entertainment
this was her story she talks about even
within the report
how she looked at the capitol one day
with her grandmother who raised her and
said
i'm going to work there one day grandma
and then when you look at her yearbook
her high school yearbook they ask you
where you see yourself in the future
she said married and working in the
government working in government well of
the two possible careers that may be
derailed by all this maybe hers won't be
one of them
correct